To record a three dimensional scene on a two dimensional surface requires some skills, some insight
into both geometry and mathematics. And if
we look at the sorts of drawings that are
done by young children or the cave paintings
of our ancient ancestors, it's clear that
they didn't have the required insight. The
drawings that they do are very simplistic
and they don't really capture the third dimension.
In fact, it took humanity quite a long time
in order to come up with an understanding
of how to do this. So this is a painting that
I love very much from the early renaissance
era and it shows, very clearly, that the underlying
geometry mathematics has been beautifully
captured because when we look at this painting,
which is after all only two dimensional, it
inspires in us as viewers, a very vivid three
dimensional perception.
In order to achieve this realism, we need
to understand the underlying geometry. And
in this particular drawing here, we can see
a lot of the geometric construction lines
put in place by the artist, in order to ensure
that the geometry of the final painting will
be correct.
This was elevated to a very popular art form
in France and what we see here is what looks
like an image of a rural landscape viewed
through a stone window in the wall of a building.
Of course this is just an illusion. It is
a two-dimensional painting on the wall of
a house. This is a modern version of it, a
street art version of it. And what this appears
to show is a portal through a building, beyond
which we can see some of the famous New York
bridges, but again it is just a two-dimensional
illusion, but this time on a very massive
scale.
Now these kinds of illusions are very, very
popular and there are a bunch of people who
do wonderful chalk street art,
and
these illusions have got a very vivid three
dimensionality to them,
an enormous amount
of work must go into creating these pieces
of art. you
can't image how much chalk is involved in
creating an image like this.
But what's going on here is these paintings
have all been created in such a way that the
stimulus that is generated on the retina of
our eyes is exactly the same as the sort of
stimulus that would be generated by looking
at a real three dimensional scene. So it's
the same stimulus that's supplied to the retina
of our eye and our brain then is interpreting
it in the normal way that it goes about interpreting
the three-dimensional world. It understands
something about scale, that things that are
far away are small and things that are close
appear to be larger.
So all of the knowledge that we have built
up in our brains about the three-dimensional
world that we actually live in, is tricked
into interpreting this sensation in a three
dimensional way.
So even if the original scene is three-dimensional
we can still play tricks on our eyes and at
first glance all of these pictures are somewhat
surprising and then the rational part of our
brain kicks into play and say's "No, the cup
can't be that big. It must be that the cup
is close and the person is far away. It can't
be that the little girl is holding tiny people
in her hand. Tiny people do not exist.
So it must be that they're full size people
far away and that the girl is close to us."
So the initial reaction is one of surprise
but then when we start to reason about it,
we understand what's going on in these scenes
and I thought It's be fun to play this game
as well, so here's my friend Chris dancing
on the tip of my finger, but of course Chris
is a full size human being, in fact he's talker
than I am.